[Music]
a piece
of valuable art going up in smoke this
week
that's a limited edition print made by
the renowned artist banksy
after paying 95 000 for it a blockchain
company
set it on fire only to later place a
digital version of the print
for sale online it's a way of art going
state of the art and
some of it is selling at a steep price
nancy
chin explains it to us
while art is in the eye of the beholder
the collectors of these digital pieces
are left holding
not much of anything that's because the
works only exist
online on monday this computer generated
work known as crossroad
was sold for a record 6.6 million
dollars
by miami collector pablo rodriguez
frailey
you can go into the loop and take a
picture of the mona lisa and you can
have it there but it doesn't have any
value because
it doesn't have the provenance or the
history of the work they're known as
non-fungible tokens or
nfts each image video or animation has
blockchain technology
certifying ownership and authenticating
them as unique
even esteemed auction house christie's
has launched its first ever sale
of digital art with bids hitting 3.5
million dollars
in climbing we are in a very unknown
territory in the first 10 minutes of
bidding we had
more than 100 bids from 21 bidders
and we were at a million dollars in 10
minutes we've never seen anything even
remotely close to that kind of activity
the russian nfts is tied to sports
trading cards
last fall the nba launched their top
shot online platform
where users can buy and trade video
highlights from games
sales for february alone climbed to
around 200 million dollars
with one collector paying 208 000 for a
clip of a lebron james slam dunk
buyers are also looking at nfts as
investments
while some warn of a bubble others like
nashville collector nate hart
say the hype is high with real potential
early nft guys have kind of been
presented with the same opportunity as
maybe
people who found bitcoin early were but
for many
these buys are about the bragging rights
so that even if you can't hang the
painting
it's at least something to hang your hat
on for cbs this morning saturday
nancy chen new york nfts they can be
complicated
to understand but in the words of our
esteemed executive producer brian
applegate who boiled it down for us
people have always copied art the money
is in what's authentic and how rare it
is and this helps do that right
so you make a work of art you deserve it
you deserve to pay for it right i get it
i just don't get it when you have that
money when you have that kind of money
you're trying to find that original you
want the original monet
you don't want a copy yeah exactly i get
it i wish i had that money yeah and then
to burn it
to burn it that's the banksy thing and
making it even more valuable in the
process
remember he shredded it yeah i remember
that and then it became more valuable
still don't get that
don't understand i'm going to shred
these scripts here's